- [Instructor] Here's an example
of a get ready for grade level course.
In this case, it's get
ready for sixth grade.
There's a couple of
interesting things here.
First of all, you can see that the course
is broken down into units like all
of our courses are broken down,
and these units are designed
to match fairly closely
to the units in sixth grade.
So, it can be used in two different ways.
The get ready for sixth
grade course, for example,
could be used at the
beginning of sixth grade,
so that students can
fill in all of the gaps
that they might have up to sixth grade,
and then they could work
on the sixth grade course.
Or, it could be done in parallel.
For example, if in the sixth grade course,
students are working
on the unit on ratios,
rates, and percentages, then
this unit right over here
in the get ready for
sixth grade can be used
to make sure that students have all
the prerequisites for
that sixth grade unit.
Now, what we recommend, because
most sixth grade students
will already have some of the mastery,
will already know many of the skills
in the get ready for sixth grade course,
we recommend that they start
with the course challenge.
By taking a course challenge,
students are going to have an opportunity
to show what they already know,
and also identify what
their existing gaps are.
If students are doing well
on the course challenge,
they can keep taking it.
They're going to get different exercises,
different items every time,
and they can accelerate
quite quickly through
the get ready for grade level course.
But of course, if they
need to fill in gaps,
they can then go to those
corresponding units.
So for example, I could go
to this unit right over here,
and do more focused skill based practice
on the things that they
haven't mastered yet.
Even within a unit,
you can also use things
like our unit tests, which
you can see right over here,
to similar to a course challenge,
accelerate through what you already know,
but then also identify the gaps
for what you don't already know.
Hopefully, all of y'all enjoy using
the get ready for grade level courses.
I just used sixth grade as an example.
It's a way to ensure that students enter
this grade level and to
whatever grade level they are,
whatever course they are in,
without those Swiss cheese gaps.
There's a way for them to fill them in,
and then continue to proceed
at their own time and pace.